you've probably never heard of Charlie
guard he de terminally-ill ten month old
baby who has now been sentenced to death
by the European Court of Human Rights an
Orwellian organisation if ever there has
been one which determined that while his
parents wants to take him to the United
States for a long shot potentially
life-saving treatment they couldn't
instead the court ruled the Great Ormond
Street Hospital for Children would
withdraw all life support killing
Charlie what was the courts
justification Charlie had to
quote-unquote die with dignity
you see Charlie suffers from a
mitochondrial disease that destroys the
muscles in the brain
there was no available treatment in the
United Kingdom and so Charlie's parents
Chris guard and Connie 8 raised 1.6
million dollars to fly him to the US for
an experimental treatment but the
hospital argued that the treatment
wouldn't help charlie and would prolong
his suffering and if they knew better
than the parents who had to suffer
through his illness and care for him
every single day
thus the hospital argued that it would
be in Charlie's best interest to die UK
courts agreed the guards then appealed
to the EU and now the court has ruled
against them with the ECHR that's the
European Commission on Human Rights
stated in stating quote Charlie would
suffer significant harm if his present
suffering was prolonged that any
realistic prospect of improvement and
the experimental therapy would be of no
effective benefit the hospital issued
its own perverse statement they said
quote our thoughts are with Charlie's
parents on receipt of the news that we
now know will be very distressing for
them today's decision by the European
Court of Human Rights marks the end of
what has been a very difficult process
and our priority is to provide every
possible support to Charlie's parents as
we prepare for the next steps
despite the hospital's statement that
would not immediately change the
standard of care his parents now report
to the hospital with will withdraw life
support tomorrow
his parents announced quote we begged
them to give us the weekend friends and
family wanted to come and see Charlie
for the last time but now there isn't
even time for that doctors said they
would not rush to turn off his
ventilator but we are being rushed not
only are we not allowed to take our son
to an expert Hospital to save his life
we also can't choose how or when our son
dies there are several levels to the
perversity here first for all the talk
of the evils of the American system of
health care at least we promote freedom
of choice and give as many options to
people for their care as they can afford
as a doctor who offered experimental
treatment said in court if Charlie had
been ill at any institution in the
United States they would immediately
have begun the treatment but in the UK a
socialized medicine country where
individual needs come
second to the preservation of the system
there is less concern with parental
rights in the u.s. we are so interested
in the freedom to obtain care that we
insist on releasing a legally brain-dead
girl to her mother so long as her mother
wishes to keep her hooked up to a
ventilator in the UK they are insistent
on withdrawing the opportunity for
life-saving care because it is better to
kill the child than keep it alive well
this case become a court proceeding
every single day the National Health
Service the NHS makes decisions about
how to ration care Bernie Sanders tweets
about how nobody should be denied care
because they can't support it but that's
what happens all the time under
socialized medicine a difference being
it's not about you it will be not being
able to afford it it's about the
government not being able to afford it
and you do not even have the capacity to
raise the money to fund the care
yourself second a government-run system
breeds a shift in control in the US the
case of Charlie guard is a major scandal
in the EU it's apparently no big deal
that's because we in the United States
like to think that we control our lives
and that as parents our priorities
matter than those of random doctors who
don't raise our kids but once you give
up control of your life and best
decisions to an impersonal government it
is nearly impossible to take back that
control this case could have been easy
the hospital could have released the
child back to the parent the hospital
didn't do it because it believed that it
had the final save and why shouldn't it
it always has the final say under the
NHS system third allowing the government
to control the value of life means
devaluing life it has been a fundamental
hallmark of Western civilization that
life ought to be preserved in spite of
pain in spite of suffering that death is
not a solution to suffering but that
notion has now been stripped away in
favor of a secularist standard of
healthy living and so in Europe
euthanasia is now available to people
who aren't even terminal people who
suffer from depression or anorexia
better to die with dignity than live
with pain that's the new map as a far
cry from the original Hippocratic oath
which overtly stated neither will I
administer a poison to anybody when
asked to do so nor will I suggest such a
course or even the Tufts Medical School
version which is usually is in the
United States which states quote above
all I must not play it God those who
value life want to keep choices about
their life in their hands rather than
turning such control over to an
impersonal government bureaucracy that
guarantees you coverage it chooses for
you Charlie darts story isn't just a
travesty of justice and an insult to
decency it's a warning for people who
think the bureaucracies are as
interested in
your healthcare as you are I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
it's a heartbreaking story now to talk a
little bit more about the Charlie Gard
story in a second plus President Trump
on Twitter again saying stuff
CNN imploding all sorts of fun coming up
but before we get to any of that I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
lyft
so right now lyft is looking for new
drivers and what makes lyft fantastic
for drivers is that you are allowed to
tip in the app when you drive to the
right ride-sharing app every trip feels
great and lyft is that ride-sharing app
you can pick your own hours you work
what you want
they are the ride-sharing company that
believes in freedom they're people
really well which means that if you're a
customer you're going to get the best
drivers let's believe that being a
ride-sharing driver should be fun if
you're choosing a ride-sharing company
to drive for go with the company that
treats you well they offer as I say
in-app inapt tipping when you drive for
lyft you keep 100% of the tips drivers
have been paid over 150 million dollars
in tips since the feature was introduced
I arrived at lift all the time I talk to
the people who drive they are very happy
and I've always felt the I've always
felt the spur to give them good tips
because they're terrific people and
great drivers lifted even taking the
guesswork out of pickups right now they
have an A & P device that uses color
coding to help passengers find their
drivers you can earn hundreds of dollars
a week if you're a driver over at lyft
plus tips if you want to make more money
you drive more it's that simple it's a
simple formula which is why 9 out of 10
lift rides get a perfect 5 star rating
for the drivers are happy right now if
you want to become a lyft driver go to
lift con ly FTT ft.com / shapiro today
that's listed com / capiro and you get a
$500 new driver bonus right out of the
gate that's lift calm / capiro lift calm
/ Schapiro limited time only terms apply
again lift great ride-sharing app we use
it all the time in the shapiro household
lift calm / Shapiro ok well now the life
issue is near and xored my heart as you
know if you've watched the program at
all or seen any of my videos on YouTube
I'm actually in Wisconsin right now
broadcasting from the road because I was
the keynote speaker at the National
Right to Life Convention and there is a
sickness that is taken hold on the left
that suggests that life is not valuable
unless it is up to your standard of what
constitutes health and happiness right
so the
the idea here is the quality of life
matters more than a life itself which is
just asinine because the fact is quality
of life changes over time just because
somebody is suffering does not mean that
their life is meaningless or valueless
this becomes particularly an issue when
the person can't speak for themselves as
with this is with this kid as a sort of
libertarian person I you know morally
don't believe in assisted suicide but as
a libertarian I sort of understand the
position at least the notion that that
if you are terminally ill and you're
going to die anyway that you may want to
pull the plug it's not something I agree
with morally and I don't think that the
government should be involved in
sponsoring it but I certainly don't
agree with the idea here which is that
if this baby was not going to have
quality of life that you like and a you
I mean the court if you don't like that
quality of life that the parents want to
preserve life I don't see how you are
able to trump their capacity to attempt
to save their own child it's just it's
just plain evil and you can hear the
suffering of the parents here's what the
parents had to say just a couple of
months ago about the government
attempting to stop them from bringing it
this is not even a matter of them asking
me the NHS to cover the cost they're
saying we'll cover the cross ourselves
just give us back our kids so we can
leave and the NHS basically said no here
is a here's the the parents of this
support is poor child what happens on
well we're going to try an appeal this
is Tim just wanting to find out and
where we can have you
is there a timescale that you have to
adhere to to really to make that appeal
yeah it was pretty weak for so now kind
of a weeks past two weeks today that
must be very difficult Chris to get your
head round doing anything like that when
you must be feeling so devastated about
what happened at the end of that almost
came I haven't got my ID Ronnie it was a
week ago and I'm still you know I can't
sleep I can't eat and I still can't get
my head around why we're not allowed to
take our boy and for treatment I so
desperately need to know and just to get
the care Chris you raised money you have
funds you could pay for the
transportation to the United States yeah
and you're prepared to do that
yeah the reason that the judges decided
that that should not be the case is that
the medical opinion is that this would
be too stressful
and too painful for your son something
right that's what they're saying that's
tougher we totally disagree with that
and he's probably the most kind of
stable baby in there and he's not in
pain he's not suffering because if he
was suffering and he was in pain we
wouldn't sit by his bed and watch him
suffer and the harshness of all of this
is partly that you're not asking for
anyone else to pay for this right so
you're just being denied the physical
transportation mm-hmm okay this is what
is truly incredible about all of us and
this is why again there is a basic rift
when it comes to the quote/unquote right
to health care people on the right say
you have the right to obtain health care
for what you are willing to pay and that
gives you the ability to make choices
about your own health care the left says
you have the right to obtain health care
regardless of ability to pay but then
says okay well the people who are
actually to pay for you get to make the
decisions the bottom line is in life
whoever controls the dollars makes the
call okay when it comes to your own
health care if you control the dollars
you make the call and if the government
controls the dollars the government
makes the call
and so in this particular case you know
there have been situations like this in
the United States like Terry Schiavo but
even that was a little bit different
because Schiavo was an adult and they
were trying to figure out what her
wishes would have been as an adult in
the United States if you're with it was
not a matter of willingness to pay or
the people will obviously have control
over the situation the parents making a
case what what the guards are going
through may be specific to their child
but socialized medicine is all about
somebody else making a decision for you
how long you ought to wait in line for a
surgery what sort of treatment you ought
to get what sort of treatment is best
for you in the United States we don't do
that so when people say you spend a lot
of money yeah we spend a lot of money
because we choose to spend a lot of that
money and that's okay yeah and we do a
Big Ideas section at the end of the show
now and at the end of the the show today
I'm going to talk about supply and
demand in healthcare because I think
people need to understand how this works
I will get to that in a little bit but
before we do that the other big news of
the day because everything is stupid is
president Trump decides that it is
imperative that you go up on Mika
Brzezinski and Joe Scarborough so as I
mentioned yesterday the only people who
benefit from the media fight with Trump
are the media and Trump that's the only
the American people don't mind a fit
from this in any way
and because there's such a reactionary
feeling on both sides because Trump
supporters are not well least a lot a
lot of Trump supporters are not even
interested in forwarding his policy
goals they're more interested in him
slapping the left whatever he does that
slaps left is seen as an ultimate good
even if it's actually counterproductive
to pushing his agenda and on the left
there so the same exact thing they're so
interested in seeing the media slap
Trump that it doesn't matter if it
undermines their own credibility at
least they're slapping Trump and Trump
is mean and bad so make up for schinsky
was on Joe Scarborough this morning and
she said something about Trump's tiny
hand she made some crack about Trump's
tiny hands now he's him a powerful man
on planet earth he's one of the richest
men on planet earth you would think that
President Trump could handle you know
somebody being mildly insulting or very
insulting I mean this is part of the job
it's part of the gig the president from
Fenn took to Twitter and he tweeted out
quote and his direct quote from his
Twitter this is the President of the
United States Donald Trump candidate not
Donald Trump reality star the most
powerful man on planet earth and a job
that used to you know we on the right
used to say why isn't Barack Obama
blaring his jacket in the Oval Office
why is he putting his shoes on the desk
in the Oval Office okay this is the guy
in the Oval Office now quote I heard
poorly rated Morning Joe speaks badly of
me
don't watch anymore then how come how
come
low IQ crazy Mika along with psycho Joe
came tomorrow logo three nights in a row
around New Year's Eve and insisted on
joining me she was bleeding badly from a
facelift I said no I mean first of all
terrible story do to me it's a really
crappy story but so there there runs
people on the right who find this just
absolutely hysterical a funny because
it's funny anytime anybody on the Left
get slap even if this is just the Three
Stooges and it's Larry Curly and Moe
pulling each other's hair and poking
each other in the eyes I'm this isn't my
favorite Trump insult Trump has had
insults that I think are much better
than this he has a very short - source
of insults low IQ crazy psycho low
energy short you know it's like eleven
insults and he just rotates them but in
any case people were going after Trump
in their very upset Trump because Trump
was talking about her bleeding from her
face lips which is utterly irrelevant to
any of this stuff and now to be fair to
be fair as I say
it is true that the that the it is true
that the media been targeting trumpet is
fair that it is proved it that Mika
Brzezinski was going after President
Trump on his appearance on his hands and
so it's not totally unfair for him to
strike back except for the fact that
she's a news commentator and he's the
President of the United States now on
the right I think people on the Left
have to understand why people on the
right respond to Trump by basically
pooh-poohing some of this stuff not
because it's right because it isn't
right okay I don't think they should be
proposed I think it's stupid I think
when the right group who is this kind of
stuff they're actually undercutting
their own credibility there's not a
single person in America who thinks less
of Mika Brzezinski because Donald's from
tweeted about her facelift and no one
who is not already in Trump's camp cares
about that sort of stuff but both are
again when you talk about the
polarization in the country right now
people on the right view from stick
people on the right view from script the
same way the people on the left view
Samantha bee so Samantha bee is utterly
unfunny if you're on the right and you
watch Samantha bee you think how does
this woman make a living she's just
awful she's ghost and nasty and vulgar
and the left just swoons for her they
love her why because it's not that she
has to tell the truth she doesn't she
just has to slap Trump so here's an
example she's slapping Paul Ryan last
night on her show I mean this is vulgar
and crude and what celebrates this kind
of stuff all the time
most people like Medicaid including
Republican people who not he'll ask you
to gut it by sending it to the states
and capping its growth rate Medicaid
sending it back to the state's
capping its growth rate we've been
dreaming of this since I've been around
since you and I were we're drinking at a
keg
[Laughter]
oh yeah well most college guys in the
90s were fantasizing about Pamela
Anderson Paul Ryan was jerking it to
thoughts of poor people losing health
care to pay protection and the left lose
it oh yes Mantha B she's the best she's
so fun okay so Samantha B is basically
to insult comedy what trumpets insult
comedy on the right now the difference
is the Trump is the President of the
United States he is not a comment on
late-night TV and I know that the right
is signing and amusing that Trump is
playing the comic on late-night TV but
it's not actually making his agenda any
more effective it's getting real left
the reason to back him around and it is
plainly rather immoral for the President
of the United States to be tweeting
about people's bloody face lifts in
order to humiliate them because they
don't like him in the media it's not a
good thing to do I mean is it fair to
say that that's not a good thing to do
are we allowed to say that anymore
nonetheless because everybody it's now
slap fight okay all of politics is a
slap fight the cause you know I used to
stand for the cause the cause was things
like pro-life the cause was things like
lower taxes and smaller government and
less regulation and more power over your
own life that was the cause now this
causes everybody slapping each other
like Kramer and like Seinfeld and
Costanza and they're just sitting around
like Napoleon Dynamite having slap I
know but we've got oh my god in a slap
that's what it is
now and you can hear the Glee right I
mean so Sarah Huckabee Sanders goes out
there and the median she says well of
course Trump said this because he always
slaps back he's got a slap back I mean
what do you want not to slap people come
on look I don't think that the
president's ever been someone who gets
attacked and doesn't push back there
have been an outrageous number of
personal attacks not just to him but to
frankly everyone around him people
actually personally attack me many times
this is a president who fights fire with
fire and certainly will not be allowed
to be bullied by liberal media and the
liberal elites within the media or
Hollywood or anywhere else I get it okay
this is the regime but buddy buddy buddy
plays buddy fight plenty fights
mathematica Magne Magne Magne but he
fights panda okay here's the deal
folks would you like him to be a
successful president or not because I
fail to see how him talking about maker
Brzezinski's facelift does anything to
establish a border wall or Obamacare
repeal or tax or
gnorm this doesn't like some of trumps
attacks are useful like when he attacks
CNN for promoting fake news and they're
actually promoting fake news that is
good that is useful I am a big fan of
evidence-based insults okay so if you
may insult someone you have to have some
evidence to back it up and the evidence
has to go to the issue at hand okay is
it like if you're having an argument
about politics then you just say about
somebody while you're fat this is not
helpful and it doesn't forward your
agenda in any way it just looks petty
and silly and ridiculous
and that's why the media is going nuts
and they're having fun with this whole
thing today and calling him a sexist the
right thing yeah Trump was mean to
Brzezinski who the hell cares about make
abortion ski except for Donald Trump
nobody watches that show
nobody realistically speaking watches
that much cable news get a
highest-ranked cable news shows like two
million viewers a night okay there are
330 million people in the country and
yet any we're supposed to think that
this is the form of winning is slapping
make a Brzezinski over her facelift I
mean like really really it's just a
waste of time now again on the on web
side of the aisle they're trying to use
this to to give themself the moral high
ground and they don't deserve the moral
high ground because they're slapping
Trump every chance they get in exactly
the same way they're just going out and
and using the stupidest possible reasons
to slap Trump and making things up I
mean this is amazing so he it ended an
entire segment a couple of nights ago
talking about refugee children from
Syria and having Elmo explain it right I
mean yes no there's no there's no media
bias Virginia Elmo just regularly
appears on CNN to explain the issues of
the day
here's tape of that Elmo can I just
start by asking you because I know you
went to visit a refugee camp in Jordan
right back in February
yes what was it like there was really
wonderful ok Elmo and Michelle Michael
Jordan together we did it was really
wonderful cuz I don't get to me I'm not
a new friends a lot of new friends and
did you find that the Syrian little
girls and little boys were a lot like
your friends here in America yeah I
really was very I Kristen because
they're lost your clothes and learn good
luck oh my god a fish vendor sesame
shoes and they loved Elmo they loved
meeting Elmo oh my god and then you
wonder why we think there's media bias
so CNN is trying to restore its
credibility here is a headline that's
and ran yesterday okay there's an actual
headline that they ran yesterday Obama's
genes game gets stronger yes really
that's a headline that they wrote so
while they're busy doing all of this
useless crap and proclaiming themselves
the most important people on earth for
checking the President of the United
States and then Trump slaps them back
with crap out baseless all of this is
stupid all of this is distraction now
the right is there's some people on the
right who are using this as an excuse to
to kill CNN right so Sean Hannity is
leading the charge on this he says it's
time to put CNN underground we're going
to kill see and then finally we're going
to kill the Beast
here we go but first let me explain how
one of the biggest anti Trump networks
has lost all their credibility and can
no longer be trusted by you the American
people now at this point we should put
CNN six-feet you see right there
underground for repeatedly spreading
lies propaganda black helicopter tinfoil
hat conspiracy theories and for
viciously trying to take down this
president now let's just look at some of
the network's many controversies and
schedule no it's true let I've talked
I've talked as much as sean has about
cnn's bias CNN is wildly biased to the
left when Shonda the 14 where he acts as
though CNN only became biased in the
last five minutes so only now have they
destroyed their credibility
they've been destroying their
credibility for years again you can find
tape of me on YouTube saying that they
were basically a propaganda outlet for
Hamas during the Gaza war three years
ago so this is nothing new I mean this
has been happening my entire adult life
at the very least but there's a sort of
opportunism where sean is saying hey
let's use this opportunity to put CNN
underground and we'll just and we'll
just throw away whatever news they
report at the same time again is any of
this design toward getting at the truth
or is this more designed at partisan
bickering and let's take out our
political opposition that matters
because if it's designed to get the
truth then it's worthwhile you know
debunked and media bias is useful if you
are attempting to get at the truth
debunking media because the entire media
outlet because you hate them and want
them to lose that's a slightly different
thing well I want to talk a little bit
more about that I want to talk about the
media is insane response to all of this
but first I want to say thank you to our
friends over at Birch gold so you should
definitely have part of your portfolio
in precious metals there
is risk of inflation there's risk of
disaster natural disaster that affects
monetary supply there's risk of economic
collapse there's risk of stock market
you could always have part of your
assets in something solid like precious
metals and that's where my friends at
Birch gold group come in they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau of right
now Gold's has been doing really well in
the market action I think it's been
rising for five or six months now
if you contact Birch gold group right
now to request a free information kit on
physical precious metals they will send
you a 16 page kit on how gold and silver
can protect your savings and how you can
legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds into a precious metals
IRA to get that kit go to birchgold.com
/femme and birchgold.com slash fed ask
all your questions get all your answers
and then when you're ready to invest in
precious metals talk to my friends over
at Birch gold again that's birchgold.com
slash been use the flash been that they
know that we sent you okay so the media
have responded to CNN has responded to
Trump being anti media and the end to
Hannity being anti media by doing what
they do best playing the victims so one
of the most irritating facts about the
way that Trump and the media play off
each other is the media claim they're
the victims so we're justified and
slapping from and then from and Sarah
Huckabee San Jose Trump is the victim
and so they're justified in slapping
mica across her face lifted head or
whatever so brian Stelter yesterday on
CNN he said that anti journalist
rhetoric is on the rise and people are
going to die I told you a week and a
half ago two weeks ago when there is
that shooting in Virginia by Bernie
Sanders supporting loon Bagla hated
Donald Trump I said be very careful that
you don't start labeling all rhetoric
you don't like potentially violence
provoking because the left will use that
logic maybe they will anyway but you can
always argue
honestly against it if you don't use it
yourself don't use the logic that
rhetoric causes violence unless there's
an open call for violence because
otherwise you are just basically trying
to rule out all rhetoric whatever I
think about Trump stupid tweets I don't
think today are causing violence against
journalists that's not what Salter
saying is people are the left right in
between our pro journalism recognize
that most journalists try to be fair and
right and then he continues but there's
an alternative view popular on partisan
websites in social media that is
straight up anti journalism these
activists and commentators don't promote
accountability they promote resentment
and hatred some of the anti journalism
spin isn't about eradicating bias or
improving news coverage it's about
trying to stamp out reporting altogether
so I generally disagree with this I
think most of the people who comment on
media bias are not attempting to stamp
out the media altogether but there is a
grain of truth to the idea that if you
spend time promoting the set rich
conspiracy and then you turn around and
you say CNN has to be put six feet under
because they are all fake news are you a
truth teller or are you just somebody
who's attempting to play a partisan game
now the West uses that criminal true
that there are some people on the right
who are more anti just anti all
journalistic outlets that ever say
anything bad about Trump they're trying
to use that grain of truth and turn that
into there's a real threat to us okay
there is no real threat to the press
there isn't okay does not say there
couldn't be a nut job out there who is
inflamed and goes and shoots a
journalist but this is true in political
rhetoric all the time and there's a
reason I travel with security but what
the left is trying to do is they're
trying to say we are on the verge
because we covered Trump badly and then
Trump is mean to us and then from says
nasty things about us we are on the
verge of a fascist takeover here in the
United States so Chris Hayes at MSNBC he
puts on the Rachel Maddow glasses and he
says Trump is going to quash the press
that's the next thing it's going to
quash the press okay just to break that
down for a moment first Amazon does not
own the Washington Post Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos does second there are no internet
taxes Amazon is now however collecting
state sales tax nationwide but president
Trump's tweet goes beyond attacking the
Washington Post as they knew something
he did as recently as yesterday the
president is very exclusively linking a
complaint about a media entity to a
threat or at least implied threat
against the corporation associated with
it did this is a candidate to during an
October speech he followed up a string
of complaints about the media with this
Amazon which through its ownership
controls the Washington Post should be
paying massive taxes okay so we talked
about that yesterday we talked about how
to sell it to us but Trump is not
actually quashing the press there has
been no active move by President Trump
to do anything remotely resembling
in the press he's limited press access
in ways that Obama limited maybe he's
done it a little bit more and that's not
good I've criticized it but this idea
that the First Amendment is under siege
that the press are all at threat of some
sort of grand government crackdown I
haven't seen one shred that in fact they
seem pretty loud to make me talk a
little bit more about this and what the
left is trying to do in building this
narrative but for that you're going to
have to go over daily wire comm become a
subscriber for $8 a month you too can be
a subscriber to daily wire comm means
you get the rest of the show live you
get to be part of the mailbag which
we'll be doing tomorrow we do live
questions on the mailbag as well you can
be part of Andrew clavin's podcast be
part of his mailbag too so lots of good
stuff happening over at Daily wire right
now if you become an annual subscriber
you get a free signed copy of the book
that I wrote with my dad about the
Chicago White Sox and baseball and
fatherhood being a son it's a really fun
it's called say it's so free signed copy
when you become an annual subscriber
also become annual right now and lock in
that rate because once we hit July 10th
the rates are about to go up not on
people who already subscribed but on new
subscribers so if you're think about
subscribing and you think maybe a three
weeks do it now lock in your lower rate
and get the benefit or if you just want
to listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud subscribe leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you